alors je vous explique je réalise un
documentaire sur les princes charmants
d'aujourd'hui donc je vais commencer en
vous demandant de me parler un peu de
vous bah écoutez moi ce que je dis c'est
très simple un mois mon quotidien c'est
défonçage de dragon sauvetage de
princesse ça oui oui j'ai mon propre
château est gentil 800 m² sur fauré tous
cas plus haut qu'avant d'être curieux un
cheval d'ailleurs le mien il fait du 100
km 1
c'est à dire que dès qu'il ya un
problème en 5 secondes sujet tué quatre
dragons en tout cas à chaque fois la
princesse était barrée de sa tour du cou
servait à rien j'ai besoin d'être tout
le temps actif tu mens disons plus quand
je défonce pas des gobelins je défonce
des dragons ouais ouais je suis un
prince a aussi besoin de se retrouve un
peu seul face à soi même c'est la
solitude c'est la réflexion aussi une
fois je me considère comme quelqu'un de
marrant je me balade la nuit un enfant
en danger ou sautent dessus tu vas pas
sur l'enfant c'est bien compris le seul
trésor que j'ai pas encore vraiment
trouvé c'est l'amour l'amour il va
tomber sur moi quand il tombera sur
blanc maculé de peinture et lorsque je
vois une femme c'est fragile au final
faut la protéger il faut faire attention
mais pour moi c'est simple il était une
fois ils vécurent heureux et eurent
beaucoup d'enfants c'est pas compliqué
ça me fait grand plaisir de pouvoir
parler avec toi comme ça parce que
en temps normal je n'arrive pas à parler
aux femmes je me lève tous les jours à
14h mais c'est toujours ça dans mon
château je suis pas si marrant qu'il
faut croiser une fille qui vient parce
que la lâcheté de médias j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut je fasse des
blacks tout le temps faire parce que
sinon ça voudrait dire que je le prends
très au sérieux et j'aime pas les gens
qui se prennent trop au sérieux
des fois je peux passer de toute la
journée dans mon château à jouer à la
place j'ai peur des toutes les femmes
que je rencontre en fait parce que je la
voie directe comme la femme de ma vie et
ça c'est flippant
elles ont aussi vachement changer les
princesses faut dire ce qui est on m'a
tellement appris apa être un match aussi
que du coup je me laisse marcher sur les
pieds pas tu m'offres que je rencontre
parce que j'ai peur de pas de les perdre
avant chaque rendez vous je me branle
pour pas être stressé je me suis brûlé
en devenir ce serait quand même super
show 206 avec mary dacquois déjà parce
que le servage pour mieux alors que moi
je viens facilement qu dépendant parce
que je pense que j'aime parce que je
suis au fond et que je préfère me font
horreur ou l'autre si jamais utilisé mon
effectif patch au graal en fait je
voudrais que tu peux affirmer comme tout
le monde et ben merci de votre
celle-ci passion appui de votre
honnêteté surtout de rien n'était
j'espère que c'était bien je vois c'est
ça que je te disais en fait c'est que
j'ai l'impression qu'il faut que je
fasse une blague là parce que parce que
sinon c'est une ambiance un peu trop
sérieuse et où tu as que ci
viel cie je fais pas de black bass et
juste juste restée à excuser moi me
faire quatre dragons là pour sauver une
meuf
c'est pourquoi l'interview